So, as kids we used to wander through here and wander through the buildings
and when we were, I would say
maybe 12 years old or so, a bunch of us were invited ...
We had a scoutmaster who
graduated from MIT and had an
affiliation and he got us, one night a
week, into the MIT swimming pool, which to me
was unbelievable. So I just saw this swimming pool back then
in the late fifties and I couldn't
believe that, you know, kids like us
would have the opportunity to go to a
building like that. And then there were
MIT students that used to volunteer, come to the Boy Scout meetings and help teach us
things about camping and physical
fitness. And it was sort of a connection.
So that's the early connection I had.
MIT used to sponsor our Boy Scout Troop. I was a Boy Scout.
It was Troop 77 and it was in building 20 maybe? On Vassar Street.
We used to meet there. Troop 77, and that was my first experience with Boy Scouts.
It was a great experience. Our scout master was Mr. Lambert,
MIT donated the facilities, so we used to get to go in, have our scout meetings and everything ...
The Boy Scouts oath is "On my honor I will do my best to
do my duty to God and country,
I will obey the Scout law.  I will help other people at all times.  I will keep myself
physically strong, mentally awake, and morally straight.
That's a wonderful thing, I've never I've never forgotten it. I learned it as a kid,
I learned it at Troop 77, MIT building 20.